Cities have a phenomenon called
the urban heat Island effect,
which is primarily due
to the generation of heat
by cars, air
conditioning, buildings, people.
We know that people in cities
are disproportionately affected
by climate change.
So I was curious to see how
we can use cities as part of
the solutions to both mitigate
and adapt to climate change.
I had read an article
about how new paint
was being developed that could
absorb some heat
and reduce temperatures
of surfaces.
And I know that endless graphics
and tables
don't really move people.
I heard about our new dean
of the Art School, Kym Pinder,
who is an expert in urban art.
I reached out to her
and I said, “hey,
is there something that we could
do together to move people
and inform them, inspire them
through art in cities?”
We decided, wow,
we should try and build
some kind of relationship,
some programing together
around community, mural making
and this cooling paint.
You know, we have a mural
that is on Mill Street
in New Haven.
That was the final result.
But I should say it's not over.
We're going to build this
project also around training up
local artists
in the art of mural making.
And so, then to actually create
a sustainable art community
for so many of the empty walls
that are in New Haven.
Art can pull you into thinking
about an issue that you
may not have wanted to,
or even thought you ever would.
And I think that's
the storytelling capability
of all the arts.
If art or cool murals can
inspire people
to have conversations and then
ultimately act on climate change
it's a success.